las infecciones asociadas con el cuidado
de la salud o infecciones hospitalarias
Hai por sus siglas en inglés son
infecciones que usted puede contraer en
un centro de salud mientras está
recibiendo tratamiento por otra afección
las bacterias tales como el
estafilococcus aureus resistente a la
meticilina
mrsa por sus siglas en inglés especie de
los enterococos y el clostridium difícil
o c DIF con frecuencia son la causa de
las infecciones hospitalarias dichas
infecciones son una de las principales
causas de muerte a nivel mundial
una de las formas más comunes de la
transmisión persona a persona de estas
bacterias se debe a la falta de higiene
adecuada de las manos cuando las
personas no se lavan adecuadamente las
manos pueden transferir los microbios de
un paciente a otro o de una parte del
cuerpo a otra en el mismo paciente
hay cuatro tipos comunes de infecciones
asociadas a los centros de salud se
puede producir una infección de una
herida quirúrgica cuando las bacterias
penetran por la incisión y se dispersan
a través de los tejidos produciendo una
infección se puede producir una
infección urinaria cuando le colocan un
catéter a la vejiga el cual es un tubo
que se emplea para drenar la orina las
bacterias pueden Ingresar a su sistema
urinario por el catéter permitiendo el
ingreso a su vejiga donde pueden
desarrollarse
se puede producir una infección a través
del torrente sanguíneo cuando le colocan
una vía central a la vena el cual es un
tubo delgado que se usa para
administrarle fluidos o medicamentos a
través de una vena grande cercana al
corazón las bacterias pueden ingresar a
la piel alrededor del sitio de inserción
o directamente a su torrente sanguíneo
donde pueden causar una infección puede
sufrir de neumonía cuando está en un
respirador o máquina de respiración
asistida las bacterias pueden Ingresar a
su garganta mientras usted está en el
respirador luego usted puede aspirar
dichas bacterias hacia sus pulmones lo
que provoca una infección que causa la
neumonía
la higiene de manos un procedimiento
sencillo efectivo y de bajo costo es el
método más importante para la prevención
de infecciones asociadas Al cuidado de
la salud todas las personas en los
centros de salud Incluyendo los
pacientes visitantes y personal médico
pueden ayudar a prevenir estas
infecciones lavándose las manos
frecuentemente
la higiene de manos se puede realizar
con jabón y agua corriente durante 40 a
60 Segundos o usando un desinfectante
para manos a base de alcohol durante 20
a 30 segundos
si usted está recibiendo atención médica
usted es parte del equipo de cuidado de
la salud y debe asegurarse de que toda
persona que está en contacto con usted
se lave las manos